This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We are in the middle of wildfire season here in California. There are more than a dozen currently burning across the state. And so, we're dedicating two episodes to this issue. Last week we explored the work of Jack Cohen. He's a Forest Service scientist who, back in the 1980s, started to argue that instead of fighting fires, we should focus more energy on building homes that were better designed to withstand fire. He helped define and popularize the idea of defensible space, which is the buffer you should create between a building on your property and the grass trees and other flammable materials
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。加州目前正处于野火季节。全州范围内目前有十几处火灾正在燃烧。因此，我们将用两期节目来探讨这个问题。上周，我们探讨了杰克·科恩的工作。他是一位林务局的科学家，早在20世纪80年代，他就开始主张，与其疲于奔命地灭火，不如投入更多精力建造更能抵御火灾的房屋。他帮助定义并推广了“可防御空间”的概念，即你应该在房产建筑与周围的草地、树木及其他易燃材料之间建立的缓冲区。
that surround it. This week, we're going to spend time in one community, in Southern California, which is frequently threatened by fire and is grappling with what it means to rebuild, over and over again. When Darryl Cagle moved to Monacito, California as a kid in 1964, it was a quiet town. The kind of place where his single mother who worked as a schoolteacher could buy a house. Monocito used to be a very normal neighborhood. Normal people with normal jobs could afford
本周，我们将走进南加州的一个社区，这里经常受到火灾威胁，并一直在努力应对不断重建所带来的困境。1964年，当达里尔·凯格尔还是个孩子时，他搬到了加州蒙特西托，那是一个安静的小镇。在那里，他身为教师的单身母亲可以买得起一栋房子。蒙特西托曾经是一个非常普通的社区。有着普通工作、普通收入的人们都负担得起那里的房子。
affordable houses there. Monocito has changed a lot since then. It's now famously home to Roblo and Oprah, and not so many single mothers and schoolteachers. The housing prices are crazy and the demographics of town are just oddly extreme, but it's a lovely place and it's where I grew up and it's very comforting to be in the place that is so familiar. Nestled between the mountains and the Pacific, right next to Santa Barbara, Montecito is very charming and very geographically isolated.
从那时起，蒙特西托发生了巨大的变化。如今，这里成了罗布·洛和奥普拉等名人的著名居所，单身母亲和教师已不多见。房价高得离谱，城镇的人口结构也变得极其怪异，但这里依然是一个可爱的地方，也是我成长的地方，身处如此熟悉的环境让人感到非常慰藉。蒙特西托坐落在群山与太平洋之间，紧邻圣巴巴拉，既迷人又在地理上相对孤立。
I can see why so many celebrities want to live there. That's Susie Cagle, the reporter for our story this week and Darrell's daughter. The landscape is this mix of desert and coasts with soaring hills, natural hot springs, and cool, dewy mornings. The hillsides are covered with evergreen chaperale, a plant community characterized by scrubby brush, and the neighborhoods are lined with fragrant eucalyptus. But Manasito's beautiful landscape is also what makes the community especially vulnerable to wildfire. The native chaperale covering the hills is drought and relatively fire resistant
我能理解为什么这么多名人想住在这里。那是苏西·凯格尔，我们本周报道的记者，也是达里尔的女儿。这里的景观融合了沙漠与海岸，有高耸的山丘、天然温泉和凉爽多露的清晨。山坡上覆盖着常绿的灌木丛，这是一种以矮小灌木为特征的植物群落，社区里种满了芬芳的桉树。但蒙特西托美丽的景观也正是使其特别容易遭受野火侵袭的原因。覆盖山丘的本土灌木丛在生长的前20年左右是耐旱且相对耐火的。
for the first 20 years or so of its life. But then it dries out into rich fire fuel. Then there's the invasive eucalyptus trees. Their shaggy bark and flammable oils make them burst into fireballs as they heat up during a wildfire. They look like matchsticks when they catch and pieces of their bark fly off to start
但之后它们会干枯，变成极易燃烧的燃料。此外还有入侵的桉树。它们粗糙的树皮和易燃的油脂使它们在野火中受热时会爆裂成火球。当它们着火时，看起来就像火柴棍，树皮碎片会飞溅出去，在附近其他地方引发火灾。
other places nearby. The slender canyons that sit below the hilltops of Montecito are cozy little spaces where that fire can easily take hold. Which it does when the town so-called Sun Downer winds blow hot dry air from the desert up over the mountains and through the canyons. The region endures a major fire once every 10 years or so.
蒙特西托山顶下方的狭窄峡谷是舒适的小空间，火势很容易在那里蔓延。当该镇所谓的“日落风”将沙漠中的热干空气吹过山脉并穿过峡谷时，火灾就会发生。该地区大约每10年就会经历一次重大火灾。
The year my dad and grandmother moved to Monocito in 1964, a wildfire called the Coyote Fire, scorched 67,000 acres just north of them. It burned 106 homes and killed one firefighter. My dad says he doesn't remember it. For this landscape, fire is predictable and it is inevitable. And coupled with a multi-year drought, it's becoming unmanageable. We had no idea that fires were going to increase insights and frequency like they have.
我父亲和祖母搬到蒙特西托的1964年，一场名为“郊狼火灾”的野火烧毁了他们以北67,000英亩的土地。它烧毁了106所房屋，并导致一名消防员丧生。我父亲说他不记得那件事了。对于这片景观来说，火灾是可预测的，也是不可避免的。再加上多年的干旱，火灾正变得难以控制。我们根本没想到火灾的规模和频率会像现在这样增加。
Maybe it's like the frog and the pot slowly coming to a boil. It's just getting worse slowly. For decades, my dad and grandmother and the other residents of Monacito exhibited a kind of stubborn pioneer streak that characterizes a lot of Californians. After fires, they'd rebuild and continue with their lives. My grandmother had been driven from her home in Texas by the drought in the 30s that sent so many dust bowl refugees fleeing for a better life. So what was a little fire? But that kind of optimism is getting harder to sustain as fires become more frequent and
也许这就像温水煮青蛙。情况正在慢慢恶化。几十年来，我父亲、祖母和蒙特西托的其他居民表现出一种顽固的开拓精神，这也是许多加州人的特征。火灾过后，他们会重建家园，继续生活。我祖母在30年代曾因干旱被迫离开德克萨斯州的家，那场干旱让许多“尘暴”难民流离失所，寻求更好的生活。所以，一点小火算什么？但随着火灾变得越来越频繁和剧烈，这种乐观情绪正变得越来越难以维持。
more intense. And as communities are forced to reckon with rebuilding again and again and again. We're re-evaluating how are we going to deal with this? Rob Hazard is the deputy fire marshal for Santa Barbara County and a fifth generation Santa Barbara resident. We are entering a new time when because of the weather and the impacts of climate change and long-term extended drought that fires have reached a new level of intensity that's causing us to have to change our tactics or strategies and we're stretched to the limit of all of our resources. 13 years after my dad arrived in Montecito, he and my grandmother faced their
随着社区被迫一次又一次地面对重建。我们正在重新评估：我们该如何应对这一切？罗布·哈扎德是圣巴巴拉县的副消防局长，也是第五代圣巴巴拉居民。我们正在进入一个新时代，由于天气、气候变化的影响以及长期的持续干旱，火灾达到了新的强度水平，这迫使我们不得不改变战术或策略，我们所有的资源都已捉襟见肘。在我父亲来到蒙特西托13年后，他和祖母面临了他们的第一次野火近距离威胁——锡卡莫尔峡谷火灾。
first close call with wildfire, the Sikamor Canyon fire. It was July 26, 1977. A young man flew his box kite into a power line on a warm summer evening, causing a spark which turned into a fire. The sundowner winds pushed the growing blaze into my dad and grandmother's dense neighborhood, which had only just been built in the early 60s. They evacuated. We got a car full of quickly gathered momentos and the clothes on our back, and we drove out, and next morning cameos and the clothes on our back and we drove out
那是1977年7月26日。一个年轻人把他的箱式风筝飞进了电线，在一个温暖的夏夜引发了火花，进而演变成火灾。日落风将不断扩大的火势推向了我父亲和祖母居住的密集社区，该社区在60年代初才刚刚建成。他们撤离了。我们装满了一车匆忙收集的纪念品和身上穿的衣服，开车逃离，第二天回来时，房子已经没了。
and next morning came back and the house was gone. The house had burned completely, from the roof down to the foundation. The foundation was fine. In fact, the chimney was left standing and the chimney was fine. 195 houses burned in the fire. Many of them, like my dads, had roofs made of wood shingles with cozy air gaps in between, perfect for flying embers to catch. Like kindling on top of houses.
房子完全烧毁了，从屋顶一直烧到地基。地基完好无损。事实上，烟囱还立着，而且烟囱也没事。那场火灾烧毁了195所房屋。其中许多房屋，像我父亲的那样，屋顶是用木瓦做的，中间有舒适的空气间隙，非常适合飞溅的余烬着火。就像房子顶上的引火物一样。
The county fire marshal at the time reported watching wood shingles lift off of one burning house, fly through the air and land on another house with a wood shingle roof. He called it a wood roof conflagration. And was there ever any question that grandmother wanted to rebuild or was that just a given? Well, she had fire insurance and rebuilding the house was covered. And she had a job working for the schools in town.
当时的县消防局长报告说，他看到木瓦从一栋燃烧的房子上掀起，飞过空中，落在另一栋有木瓦屋顶的房子上。他称之为“木屋大火”。当时有人质疑祖母是否想重建吗，还是说这是理所当然的？嗯，她有火灾保险，重建房屋在保险范围内。而且她在镇上的学校有份工作。
And I don't think there was much question about it. If there's an upside to destructive wildfires, it's that they give a community the chance for a design do over. Towns have a rare opportunity to modify the landscape and rebuild houses in ways that make them more resistant to disasters in the future. Through the 50s and 60s, Manicido made a handful of changes to prepare for future fires. The Forest Service tore up some of the flammable shop overall with bulldozers and doused it with herbicide until fears over toxic chemicals and a growing environmental movement scrapped
我不认为有什么疑问。如果说破坏性野火有什么积极的一面，那就是它们给了社区一个重新设计的机会。城镇拥有难得的机会来改变景观，并以更具灾害抵御能力的方式重建房屋。在50和60年代，蒙特西托做出了一些改变以应对未来的火灾。林务局用推土机铲除了一些易燃的灌木丛，并喷洒除草剂，直到70年代对有毒化学物质的担忧和日益增长的环保运动叫停了该项目。
the project in the 70s. In especially fire-prone neighborhoods, the county began requiring people to build their houses with fire-resistant roofs and walls, and with wide areas of clear open space around them, what's known as defensible space. Each new disaster inspires a new edit. When my grandmother rebuilt, she changed the design of their house. Those nightmarish wood roofs were now banned,
在特别容易发生火灾的社区，县政府开始要求人们用防火屋顶和墙壁建造房屋，并在房屋周围留出大面积的空地，即所谓的“可防御空间”。每一次新的灾难都会激发新的修订。当祖母重建时，她改变了房子的设计。那些噩梦般的木屋顶现在被禁止了，
so she replaced hers with concrete and paved over the tiny surrounding yard. They did what they could to make their space more defensible. But there can be limits to the effectiveness of defensible space. That's especially true in a dense community where people have small lots. We have neighbors and neighbors have rights and neighbors want trees and you can only clear brush from your own land. So even if you're diligent about keeping your land carefully maintained, your neighbor
所以她换成了混凝土屋顶，并铺平了周围的小院子。他们尽其所能使空间更具防御性。但可防御空间的有效性是有限的。在人们地块狭小的密集社区尤其如此。我们有邻居，邻居有权利，邻居想要树木，而你只能清理自己土地上的灌木。所以即使你勤奋地维护自己的土地，你的邻居
might have a propane barbecue or a tall stand of lovely eucalyptus trees, and their house could catch your house on fire. In Manacito, preventing fires can often prove more controversial than rebuilding after them. Prescribed fires set and managed by firefighters were once considered an effective way to burn off fuel. But in coastal California, with its part chaperale, they're hardly done anymore. The so-called controlled fires can easily grow out of control
可能有一个丙烷烧烤架或一排高大的漂亮桉树，他们的房子可能会导致你的房子着火。在蒙特西托，预防火灾往往比火灾后的重建更具争议性。由消防员设置和管理的规定火灾曾经被认为是烧掉燃料的有效方法。但在加州沿海地区，由于其灌木丛，这种方法几乎不再使用了。所谓的受控火灾很容易失控，
and destroy valuable ecosystems and neighborhoods. And Ridgetop fire breaks are expensive to maintain and ugly. These big stretches of cleared land are meant to make space for fire engines, hoses, and hand tools. They provide firefighters with ready access to the front. But residents of affluent communities don't like to see big scars across the lush mountain sides, even when it's for their own protection. So Rob Hazard and other county firefighters are tasked with a losing battle, fighting nature and civilization without control over either one.
并摧毁宝贵的生态系统和社区。而且山脊防火带的维护成本高昂且难看。这些大片的空地旨在为消防车、软管和手动工具腾出空间。它们为消防员提供了进入前线的便捷通道。但富裕社区的居民不喜欢看到郁郁葱葱的山坡上留下巨大的伤疤，即使这是为了他们自己的保护。因此，罗布·哈扎德和其他县消防员肩负着一场注定失败的战斗，在无法控制自然和文明的情况下与两者抗争。
A lot of our discussions revolve around while community planning, that's really where we need to be tackling this. We need to plan our communities better. We need to build our houses more durable and resilient and resistant to combustion. We need to stop building in the wildlands. But the sad truth is that we've already built out our communities. And we're only adding to them. As those communities grow and spread inland, they've gotten closer to what used to be considered wilderness. Now, it's called the Wildland Urban Interface. Researchers expect
我们的大部分讨论都围绕着社区规划，这确实是我们解决问题的关键所在。我们需要更好地规划我们的社区。我们需要让房屋更耐用、更具韧性、更抗燃烧。我们需要停止在荒野地区建设。但可悲的事实是，我们已经建成了我们的社区，而且还在不断扩张。随着这些社区向内陆生长和蔓延，它们越来越接近曾经被认为是荒野的地方。现在，它被称为“荒野-城市交界处”。研究人员预计，
that a million new houses will be built in those high-fire hazard areas of California in the coming decades. As urban populations have moved closer to the wildlands, we get a whole new generation of people who are familiar with the risks inherent with living next to the wildlands in Southern California. Actually, statewide now. The reality is there really isn't a wilderness in Southern California. Anywhere in the state of California, we can have a fire start in a wilderness area and be in the back door of a major metropolitan area in four or five hours.
未来几十年，加州这些高火灾风险地区将新建一百万套房屋。随着城市人口向荒野地区迁移，我们迎来了一整代人，他们熟悉在南加州荒野地区旁居住所固有的风险。实际上，现在是全州范围内的风险。现实情况是，南加州真的没有荒野了。在加州的任何地方，火灾都可能在荒野地区开始，并在四五个小时内蔓延到大都市区的后院。
At the same time, communities are encroaching on what used to be wildlands. Climate change is making wildfires more frequent and intense. It's a dangerous mix. But the way we live through fire has stayed remarkably the same. When a community burns, local authorities rush to issue new building permits. And with California and the grips of a housing crisis that has only intensified since the 1970s, it can seem crazy or not to rebuild houses, even though the threat of fire is now year round.
与此同时，社区正在侵占曾经的荒野。气候变化使野火变得更加频繁和剧烈。这是一个危险的组合。但我们经历火灾的方式却惊人地保持不变。当一个社区被烧毁时，地方当局会急于发放新的建筑许可证。而加州正处于自70年代以来不断加剧的住房危机中，重建房屋似乎并不疯狂，尽管火灾威胁现在是全天候的。
There is no fire season anymore. My grandmother died in 1999, and my dad moved into the Monocito House. In 2008, 31 years after the Sikamurkian fire, the house was threatened once again. This fire, called the T-fire, was eerily similar to the fire that had burned their house down all those years ago. It swooped in really fast and it took out a similar number of houses and it was quite nearby and very scary. It was like a hundred yards nearby. Well it burned a whole bunch of houses on the
现在已经没有所谓的火灾季节了。我祖母于1999年去世，我父亲搬进了蒙特西托的房子。2008年，在锡卡莫尔峡谷火灾31年后，这所房子再次受到威胁。这场被称为“T火灾”的火灾与多年前烧毁他们房子的那场火灾惊人地相似。它迅速袭来，摧毁了数量相当的房屋，而且离得很近，非常可怕。离我们只有一百码远。它烧毁了隔壁街区的一大片房子，烟雾缭绕，空气中满是余烬，我们本该早点撤离的。
next street a block over and smoke was swirling and there were embers in the air and we should have gotten out earlier. We're on one of the mini hilltop road sides and Montecito Hill where completely surrounded by flames you can see how tall these flames are. It is just a few feet. The T-fire destroyed 210 homes in my dad's neighborhood. His house survived, and despite the near miss, again he chose to say. The constant threat had made him somewhat blase, like a lot of people in the community. When another fire sparked in the Santa Barbara Hills just
我们当时在蒙特西托山的一条小型山顶道路上，完全被火焰包围，你可以看到这些火焰有多高。只有几英尺远。T火灾摧毁了我父亲社区的210所房屋。他的房子幸存了下来，尽管再次险些被毁，他还是选择留下。持续的威胁让他变得有些冷漠，就像社区里的许多人一样。当六个月后圣巴巴拉山再次发生火灾——“海苏斯塔火灾”时，他一点也不担心。当然，你可以从他家看到山上的火焰，但它们隔了两个峡谷，而且在他和火灾之间所有能烧的东西都已经烧过了。但就在去年，发生了一件事，让人们感到了一种新的危险感。首先，又发生了一场火灾，直到最近，它还是加州历史上最大的火灾。在其他新闻报道的日子里，南加州的数千名消防员正在与时间赛跑，以防止大规模野火蔓延到附近的社区。托马斯火灾烧毁了南部城市近一千所房屋，之后
six months later, the Haysu Sita fire, he didn't worry at all. Sure, you could see flames in the hills from his house, but they were two canyons over, and everything that could burn between him and the fire had already burned anyway. But just this past year, something happened that made people feel a new sense of danger. First, there was another fire, until very recently, the largest in California history. In the days of the other news, thousands of firefighters in Southern California are racing against the clock to prevent a massive wildfire from spreading into nearby neighborhoods. The Thomas Fire burned through nearly a thousand homes in cities to the south, before the
风向将其吹向了北部的蒙特西托。一夜之间，在山脚下，居民们敬畏而惊恐地注视着大火。2017年12月16日上午，火势在我父亲家五个街区外肆虐。火势如此之近，以至于卫星热图显示火灾范围完全覆盖了他的房子。看起来它已经没了。我从未见过我们身后的所有山脉那样燃烧。
wind moved it north to Manacito. Over night in the foothills, residents watched the blaze in awe and horror. On the morning of December 16, 2017, the fire was raging five blocks away from my dad's house. It got so close that at one point, the satellite heat map showed the fire perimeter completely covering his house. It looked like it was gone. And I had never seen all of the mountains behind us burn like that.
它们完全被剥光了。看起来就像没有任何植被生长的沙漠山脉。看到这一幕令人震惊。对于如此大的区域，整个山脉都是如此。托马斯火灾烧毁了超过280,000英亩的土地，造成了超过20亿美元的损失。它最终烧到了其他近期火灾留下的新鲜伤疤处，由于没有灌木丛和其他燃料来维持火势，它自动熄灭了。蒙特西托只有三所房屋被毁。镇上的人以为他们幸免于难，但随后雨来了。2018年1月9日清晨，一场风暴袭击了圣巴巴拉。
They were completely denuded. They looked like desert mountains that don't have anything growing on them. A shocking thing to see. For so large an area, a whole mountain range. The Thomas Fire burned more than 280,000 acres and caused more than two billion dollars in damages. It eventually burned into these still fresh scars from other recent fires and without chaperale and other fuel to keep it going, it simply put itself out. Only three houses were destroyed in Monocito. People in the town thought they'd been spared, but then the rain came. In the early morning of January 9th, 2018, a storm pummeled Santa Barbara.
蒙特西托上方的山脉在短短五分钟内降下了半英寸的雨。急诊医生史蒂夫·米尔斯当时醒着听风暴的声音。他和家人几年前才搬到蒙特西托。那天晚上大家都睡着了，但我睡不着。那是一种半梦半醒的状态。我听到了雷声，我以为是雷声。我想，天哪，这雷声真奇怪，持续了30秒。我的意思是，什么样的雷声会轰鸣那么久。
Half an inch of rain fell on the mountains above Monocito in just five minutes. E.R. Dr. Steve Mills was up listening to the storm. He and his family had moved to Monocito just a few years before. That night everyone went to sleep and I couldn't. It was one of these things where you're in that sort of half awake, half asleep state. And I heard thunder, what I thought was thunder. And I thought, gosh, that's a weird thunder to last for 30 seconds. I mean, what thunder rumbles that long.
然后我的大脑终于清醒过来，我跳下床，心想，好吧，我得确保每个人都平安。当我走过时，我向外看，门口有泥浆。房子被泥浆、岩石和树木的河流包围了。我们房子前面有一具尸体。
And then my brain finally turned on enough that I leapt out of bed and, okay, I'm just gonna make sure everybody's okay. And then as I walk by, I look outside and there's mud at the door. The house had been enveloped in a river of mud, rocks and trees. There was a dead body right in front of our house.
有很多人被冲到了我们这一带，这太可怕了。这种碎片流，也就是有些人误称为泥石流的东西，是几周前烧毁山脉的托马斯火灾的直接结果，这一切都归结于灌木丛。火灾后，覆盖在灌木叶子上的蜡状物质
There was a number of them washed down stream into our area and it was frightening. This debris flow, or what some people mistakenly call a mud slide, was the direct result of the Thomas fire that had burned the mountain's bear just weeks before, and it all goes back to Chaparral. After the fire, the waxy substance that coats the Chaparral leaves
作为一层薄膜留在了烧焦的土壤上。那层油性涂层使地面无法渗水，所以雨水在上面滑过，而不是渗入。当雨水在土壤上掠过时，没有灌木丛来阻挡它。托马斯火灾吞噬了所有的植物。这是罗布·哈扎德再次发言。这样做完全剥夺了山坡上任何可以阻挡土壤、岩石、碎片的东西，以至于任何降雨量都会导致某种
was left as a film across the scorched soil. That oily coating made the ground impervious to water, so rain slipped across it instead of soaking in. As the rain skimmed across the soil, there was no shaperow to restrain it. The Thomas fire had devoured all the plants. Here's Rob Hazard again. And what that does completely strips the hillside of anything that can hold back, soil, rock, debris, to such an extent that any amount of rainfall is going to result in some kind
碎片流。然后，不幸的是，我们当然知道发生了什么。我们经历了数百年来从未见过的强降雨。在这种景观中，洪水本质上是火灾的第二阶段。雨水冲下山坡进入城镇。随着流动，水流带着泥浆、树木和岩石从陡峭的山坡上冲下。即使是经验丰富的救援队也对破坏的程度感到震惊。
of debris flow. And then, unfortunately, of course, we know what happened. We had rainfall intensities that hadn't been seen in hundreds of years. In this landscape, flood is essentially the second stage of fire. Rain came rushing down the hills into the town. As it flowed, the water carried mud, trees, and rocks off the steep hills. Even seasoned rescue teams are shocked by the magnitude of the destruction.
我们没见过这种情况。我的意思是，这是彻底的毁灭。多处房屋被完全摧毁。像小房子那么大的巨石漂浮在深达15英尺以上的泥浆河流中。一些碎片流的速度接近每小时30英里。巨石猛烈地撞击一栋房子，导致煤气管道爆炸。在整个住宅区，泥浆下已经没有房子可挖了。房子直接消失了。
We don't see this. I mean, it is complete devastation. I'm multiple, multiple homes that are completely destroyed. Boulder is the size of small houses floated down several dense rivers of mud, more than 15 feet deep. Some of the debris flows reach speeds of close to 30 miles per hour. Boulders smashed into one house so violently that the gas main exploded. On whole residential blocks, there weren't houses to dig out under the mud. The houses were simply gone.
有些房屋从地基上被抹去并消失了，另一些则被撕裂成木头和钢材的堆积物。我父亲没事，但他许多邻居却没那么幸运。超过400所房屋受损或被毁，约占全镇的十分之一。数百人不得不通过直升机获救。23人死亡。两人从未被找到。房子目前无法居住，他们在进行房产维修时住在出租屋里。在他们开始清理房屋下的泥浆和碎片之前，他们从院子里清除了65卡车的泥浆和碎片。
Some homes were wiped off their foundations and vanished, others torn into piles of wood and steel. My dad was fine, but many of his neighbors were not. More than 400 homes were damaged or destroyed, about a tenth of the whole town. Hundreds of people had to be rescued by helicopter. 23 were killed. Two were never found. ["Milk's Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry Ferry F House is currently uninhabitable, and they're living in a rental while they make repairs to the property. They had 65 truckloads of mud and debris removed from their yard before they could even begin removing the mud and debris from under their home.
一些房屋被毁的人已经搬走了，史蒂夫的妻子也想这样做。她看到了那道20英尺高的泥墙，这太可怕了，那种程度的恐惧在她的脑海中留下了印记。所以她真的不想住在这里。但目前，他们正与保险公司进行旷日持久的斗争，在问题解决之前他们无法修理房子，所以他们必须留下来。碎片流在技术上属于洪水，但由于它们是由火灾引起的，加州法律规定它们在火灾保险范围内，蒙特西托的每个人都有这种保险。
Some of the people whose homes were destroyed have moved away and Steve's wife would like to do that too. She saw this 20-foot mud damn and it was frightening and that sort of, that leaves you marked your mind, just her degree. So she really doesn't want to live here. But for now, they're in a protracted battle with their insurance company and they can't fix their house until that's resolved, so they have to stay. Debris flows are technically floods, but since they're caused by fire, California law mandates that they're covered by fire insurance, which everyone in Montecito has.
当物理基础设施失效时，接管的是金融基础设施。比起政府，似乎是保险公司在决定人们可以在加州的什么地方以及如何生活。保险公司抱怨说他们是在补贴糟糕、冒险的决策，但在大多数情况下，他们并没有停止为人们提供保险。他们只是提高了价格，使加州对每个人来说都变得更加排外、更加昂贵。房地产市场有所降温，但蒙特西托整体上仍然令人向往。如果说有什么变化的话，那就是去年没有被火灾或洪水摧毁的每一处房产的价值都上涨了。
It's the financial infrastructure that takes over when physical infrastructure fails. More than government, it's insurance companies that seem to make the decisions about where and how people can live in California. Insurance companies complain that they're subsidizing poor, risky decisions, but for the most part, they don't stop insuring people. They just increase prices, making California an even more exclusive, expensive place to live for everyone. The housing market has cooled somewhat, but Monacito as a whole remains desirable. If anything, the value of every property that wasn't destroyed by fire or flood in the last year has only gone up.
随着山上的灌木丛被烧光，蒙特西托的整个风险范式已经改变，工程挑战也随之改变。火灾的威胁还要再过20年。现在的当务之急是下一次降雨何时到来，再次将城镇埋在泥浆中。我的意思是，在火灾后发生这种强度的降雨并从山坡上滑落，这种情况不会经常发生。这是否意味着它不会再发生？
With the shopper out burnt out of the hills, the whole risk paradigm in Monocito has changed, as have the engineering challenges. The threat of fire is another 20 years off. The immediate concern now is when the next rain might come and bury the town in mud again. I mean, to have that amount of intensity that follows up a fire that has slipped off the hillside, that's not gonna happen very often. Does it mean it's not gonna happen again?
当然不是。蒙特西托发生更多的碎片流是不可避免的。事实上，整个地区就是几十万年前这样形成的。正是它们雕刻了那些美丽的峡谷，创造了那些风景如画的小溪。这里的房主几十年来一直在巨石周围进行景观美化，却没有意识到它们是如何到达
Of course not. More debris flows are inevitable in Montecito. In fact, they're how the whole area was formed hundreds of thousands of years ago. They're what carved those lovely canyons and created those picturesque creeks. Homeowners here have been landscaping around the boulders and their yards for decades, without realizing how they got
那里的以及它们意味着什么。现在地质学家正以新的紧迫感研究该地区。他们发现了距今12.5万年到1000年不等的巨大地壳移动碎片流。这并不是碎片流第一次用泥浆和岩石墙淹没蒙特西托。这是一个有规律的重复循环，不知何故每个人还是设法忘记了。
there and what they met. Now geologists are studying the area with new urgency. They found huge earth-shifting debris flows as old as 125,000 years and as young as 1,000 years. This wasn't the first time a debris flow had flooded Montecito with a wall of mud and rocks. It's a regular repeating cycle that somehow everyone still manages to forget.
在我们地区，我们非常习惯如何处理火灾。人们知道如何处理火灾。但这让他们在处理其他紧急情况时产生了一定程度的自满。达斯·威廉姆斯是代表蒙特西托的民选县监事。作为一个非建制社区，蒙特西托没有自己的政治决策机构。而且它喜欢这样。该镇以前曾投票表决过建制，但从未通过。这里有一种典型的加州自由意志主义倾向，重视私有财产权利，同时保持紧密的当地社区控制和支持。
In our area, we are very used to how to deal with fires. People know how to deal with fire. But it loels them into a certain amount of complacency in how to deal with other emergencies. Das Williams is the elected county supervisor who represents Manicito. As an unincorporated community, Monacito doesn't have its own political decision-making bodies. And it likes it that way. The town is voted on incorporation before and it's never passed. There's a classic California libertarian street here, which values private property rights alongside tight local community control and support.
到目前为止，圣巴巴拉县让蒙特西托的居民重建变得相当容易。他们开发了一个简化的审查流程，并且大多让房主自行选择重建方式。达斯·威廉姆斯只是希望他们能做出正确的选择。像这样的时刻确实为人们提供了反思的机会。也许如果我能看看我是否能在那个范围之外建造，或者做出不重建的个人决定，会更好。但现在每个人都必须考虑到两种威胁：火灾和洪水。你可以清理院子里的灌木，安装防火壁板，建造混凝土屋顶，甚至购买可以
So far, Santa Barbara County has made it pretty easy for the residents of Montecito to rebuild. They've developed a streamline review process and are mostly letting homeowners rebuild as they choose. Dos Williams is just hoping they'll choose well. Moments like this do provide an opportunity for people to soul-searching go. Maybe it's better if I either see if I can build outside of that envelope which is why we have provided more flexibility on rebuilding or make the individual decision to not rebuild at all. But now everyone has to build with two threats in mind, fire and flood. You can clear brush from yards, install fire-resistant siding, build concrete roofs, and even by systems that will
向你的房子喷射阻燃胶的系统。你可以封闭地基上方的爬行空间，并用桩基抬高你的房子，但你无法让房子免受以每小时30英里速度撞击的巨石的破坏。美国建筑师协会正在权衡设计建议，联邦紧急事务管理局更新了其2012年的洪水风险地图，以更好地说明火灾后的危害。
shoot flame retardant goo all over your house. You can close the crawl spaces above your foundation and lift your house up on pilings, but you can't make a home impervious to a boulder smashing into it at 30 miles an hour. The American Institute of Architects is weighing in with design recommendations, and FEMA updated its flood risk maps from 2012 to better account for the hazards that follow a fire.
县政府能做的最好的事情就是要求人们在这些新准则内重建，这些准则要求在新建的洪泛区内的房屋必须抬高在地基或桩基上。我们已经决定，只要人们遵守联邦紧急事务管理局的恢复地图和地图上的高程，我们就不会告诉他们不能重建。但这并不意味着在所有情况下重建都是一个好主意。达斯·威廉姆斯实际上希望看到某些易受洪水影响的社区保持空置，以实现
The best the county can do is require people to rebuild within these new guidelines, which call for houses and the newly expanded floodplain to be raised up on elevated foundations or pylons. We've made the decision that we're not going to tell people that they can't rebuild as long as they comply with the FEMA recovery maps and the elevations in that map. But that does not mean that rebuilding is a good idea in all cases. Doss Williams would actually like to see certain flood prone neighborhood stay empty for the
更大的利益，他正在考虑地方政府可以采取的措施。如果县政府能筹集到资金，征用权将使县政府有权为了公共安全而征用人们的房屋和土地。嗯，那里的大部分土地——这是我们改善局势的一个巨大制约因素——都在私人手中，而且是高价值的私人手中，这使得政府很难通过收购土地来大规模改变局面。蒙特西托的一块土地可能价值超过一百万美元，而达斯·威廉姆斯
greater good, and he's considering boulder steps local government could take. Eminent domain would empower the county to take people's homes and land in service of public safety if the county could come up with the money. Well the majority of land out there, and this is a big constraint on our ability to improve the situation, is in private hands, and it's in private hands with pretty high property values, which makes it very hard for government to acquire a land to massively change the equation. A single lot of land in Montecito can cost more than a million dollars, and dozzoliums
希望在当地慈善机构的帮助下购买其中的大部分。靠近小溪的地块将保持空置作为纪念公园，并作为缓冲区，在未来的碎片流和房屋之间创造更多空间。还有其他政府可以尝试的更大的基础设施项目，而个人房主无法做到。在大型风暴来临前，可以在山坡上安装金属网，在山体碎片到达城镇之前将其拦截。而山中现有的11个碎片盆地，类似于旨在拦截
would like to buy a lot of it, with the help of local philanthropy. Parsols near creeks would be kept vacant as memorial parkland and wood act as a buffer, creating more space between future debris flows and homes. There are other bigger infrastructure projects that the government could try that just aren't available to individual homeowners. Metal nets could be installed on hill sides before large storms to catch chunks of the mountain before they reach the town. And the 11 existing debris basins in the mountains, which are kind of like dams designed to catch
从山上冲下的巨石和树木的水坝，可以进行扩建和现代化改造。达斯·威廉姆斯正在努力为这些新的更大的盆地筹集资金。那些不喜欢防火带外观的人似乎不太可能接受破坏他们美丽山坡的冷冰冰的混凝土大坝和超大钢网。但如果达斯·威廉姆斯如愿以偿，他们可能就没得选了。我父亲没有受到1月洪水的影响，但他的房子正处于历史性碎片流的中间。他陡峭的车道底部有一条小溪，标志性的巨石排列在他邻居的院子里。
large rocks and trees flooding down the hill, could be expanded and modernized. DOS Williams is working to raise money for those new bigger basins. The same people who don't like the look of fire breaks seem unlikely to embrace stark concrete dams and oversized steel nets marring their beautiful hillsides. But if Doss Williams has his way, they may no longer have a choice. My dad wasn't affected by the January floods, but his house sits right in the middle of his historic debris flow. There's a creek at the bottom of his steep driveway and the telltale boulders line his neighbor's yards.
我给他看了联邦紧急事务管理局的地图，上面把他标在了红色区域。他还没见过。看着这张地图，看到指向我们小溪的红色区域，这让我很困扰。但对我父亲来说，地图似乎与他的生活现实是分开的。到目前为止，房子经历了每一次灾难，除了那一次。按照他的计算，这些几率相当不错。
I showed him the FEMA map that puts him in the red zone. He hadn't seen it yet. It bothers me to look at this map and see the red area pointing into our creek. But for my dad, the map appears to exist separate from his lived reality. So far, the house is made it through every disaster, but one. By his count, those odds are pretty good.
任何其他证据都无法说服他。它需要烧毁两次，我才能感觉到它烧毁的频率。我的意思是，烧毁一次，我的数据点不够。我父亲的数学逻辑似乎很可疑，但他个人对威胁的评估似乎基于一种假设，即灾难能塑造性格。我父亲喜欢说，因为他经历过失去一切，所以他与自己拥有的东西有着更健康的关系。另外，他说，随着气候变化，难道每个地方不都是灾难多发地吗？
Any other evidence just isn't persuasive. It needs to burn down twice for me to get a sense of how often it burns down. I mean, burning down once I don't have enough data points. My dad's math seems dubious, but part of his personal threat appraisal seems to be an assumption that disaster builds character. My dad likes to say he has a healthier relationship with the stuff he owns because he's experienced losing it all before. Plus, he says, with climate change, isn't every place disaster prone?
为什么不至少坚持他所熟悉的恐惧呢？这是一个我热爱的地方，它让人感到慰藉和熟悉，你知道我可以搬到加州的其他地方，然后遇到地震。我可以搬到其他地方，让飓风摧毁佛罗里达州的所有中部地区。我可以搬到休斯顿，让洪水摧毁整个城市，然后搬到新奥尔良，让洪水摧毁整个城市。你知道，每个地方都有自己的问题。我面临的问题是房子每57年烧毁一次。希望超过57年。确实，无论你去哪里，都有风险，即使是在世界另一端。我们有一个关于日本沿海社区如何在灾后警告后代防范海啸风险的故事。正如达里尔·凯格尔在故事结尾所指出的，居住在任何地方都有风险，
Why not at least stick with the horror he knows? It's a place I love and it's comforting and familiar and you know I could move somewhere else in California and have an earthquake. I could move somewhere else and have a hurricane take out all the middle of Florida. I could move to Houston and have floods destroy the whole city, then move to New Orleans, have floods destroy the whole city. You know, every place has their issue. I've got the issue of a house that burns down once every 57 years. Hopefully more than 57. It's true that anywhere you go, there are risks, even halfway around the world. We have a story about how coastal communities in Japan warn future generations about the risk of tsunamis after this. As Darryl Kegel noted at the end of that story, there are risks associated with living anywhere,
但像蒙特西托这样的地方，存在持续的威胁，重要的是不要让对过去灾难的记忆消退到人们在现在做出错误选择的地步。克拉科夫在这里谈论日本人民如何向后代发出关于海啸危险的警告。在安义市下方的一个山坡上，有一块巨大的古老石头，上面刻着一个警告，当地人认为这多次拯救了他们的沿海村庄。上面刻着一个警告，当地人认为这多次拯救了他们的沿海村庄。翻译过来，上面写着：不要在这个点以下建造任何房屋。高处的住所是我们后代的和平与和谐。记住大地震海啸的灾难。那么，是什么让他们的祖先决定必须竖立这块特殊的石头呢？
but there are places like Manicido where there is a persistent threat and it's important not to let the memory of past disasters fade away so much that people make poor choices in the present. Krakow is here to talk about how people in Japan sent warnings to future generations about the dangers of tsunamis. There's this huge old stone sitting on a hillside below Aniochi, Japan, and there's a warning carved into it which locals credit with repeatedly saving their coastal village. there's a warning carved into it, which locals credit with repeatedly saving their coastal village. Translated, it reads, do not build any homes below this point. High dwellings are the peace and harmony of our descendants. Remember the calamity of the great tsunamis. So what happened that made their ancestors decide they need to put up this particular stone?
嗯，这要追溯到19世纪90年代，当时海岸外发生了地震，随后是一对非常具有破坏性的海啸。巨大的海浪升起超过100英尺，摧毁了数千所沿海房屋。事后，安义市的当地人进行了重建。但他们在20世纪30年代再次受到袭击。所以在那时，他们决定我们必须把城镇搬到山上，并留下了这个警告标志。因此，当1960年和2011年再次发生大海啸时，村庄安全地坐落在高水位线之上。这是一个如此令人惊叹的故事，而且这并不是日本唯一的
Well, it started way back in the 1890s, with an earthquake off the coast, followed by a pair of really devastating tsunamis. Huge waves rose up over 100 feet and destroyed thousands of coastal homes. In the aftermath, locals in Aniochi rebuilt. But then they got hit again in the 1930s. So at that point, they decided we've got to move the town up hill and they left behind this warning marker. So when big tsunami struck in 1960 and then again in 2011 the village sat safely above the high watermark. That's such an amazing story and this isn't the only
海啸石，对吧？是的。沿海有数百块这样的石头，其中一些可以追溯到500多年前。它们也可以非常大。有些高达10英尺。它们都是关于在哪里建造的吗？它们都是关于分区法规的吗？嗯，并非全部。其中一些更像是过去灾难的纪念碑。标记墓地或列出海啸受害者。另一些只是提供这些普遍的警告，即在地震期间前往高地以逃避海浪。也有城镇无视更具体的警告，在靠近
tsunami stone in Japan right? Right. There are hundreds of these along the coast, some of which date back over 500 years. And they can be really big too. Some of us tall is 10 feet. Are they all really tall and you wear or wear not to build? Are they all like about zoning regulations? Well, not all of them. Some of them are more like memorials to past disasters. Marking gray u-sites or listing off tsunami victims. Others just offer these blanket warnings to head for higher ground during earthquakes and escape the waves. And there are cases too of towns ignoring more specific warnings and building close to
海岸的地方建造，然后在后来的海啸中面临严重破坏的情况。那么人们现在还会关注这些石头吗，还是它们在这一点上基本上只是历史标志？作为实际的警告，它们已经相当过时了。有时仍会竖立新的石头，但更多是作为纪念碑而不是警告。如今，日本拥有许多高科技预警系统和标记非常清晰的疏散路线。他们还设计了更好的房屋，并竖立了海堤来保护海岸。虽然，正如我们在2011年所看到的，这些并不总是足够的。
the shore than facing serious destruction in a later tsunami. So do people still pay attention to these stones or are they basically just historical markers at this point? As a practical warning, they're pretty outdated. New stones still get put up sometimes, but more as memorials than warnings. These days, Japan has a lot of high-tech warning systems and really well-marked evacuation routes. They also engineer better houses and put up sea walls to protect the coast. Though, as we saw in 2011, those aren't always enough.
所以，如果你想看这些令人难忘和感人的海啸石的照片，你可以访问我们的网站 snininipi.org。谢谢。我总是可以说出某种原因。这是一个海啸标志。我不知道。好吧。我不会强求。本周的《99%隐形》由苏西·凯格尔和我们的资深编辑德莱尼·霍尔制作，由谢雷夫·乌索进行混音和技术制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的资深制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
So, if you want to see pictures of these haunting and evocative tsunami stones, you can visit our website at snininipi.org. Thanks. And I can say always some reason. It's a tsunami sign. I don't know. Okay. I'm not going to push it. 99% of the visible was produced this week by Suzy Kegel and our senior editor Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Seref Uso, music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
团队的其他成员包括艾弗里·特罗尔曼、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、泰兰·马扎，以及我罗曼·马斯。感谢汤姆·科利根提供的研究协助。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。访问 radiotopia.fm。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。
Rest of the team is Avery Trollman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald Vivian Lee, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Thanks to Tom Colligan for research assistance. We are a project of 91.7KALW in St. Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Fun mall at radiotopia.fm You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
团队的其他成员包括Avery Trollman、Joe Rosenberg、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Lee、Terran Mazza以及我Roman Mars。感谢Tom Colligan提供的研究协助。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。99% Invisible是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请访问radiotopia.fm了解更多信息。您可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But this week on the 99PI website, an article about the great fire of 1910 that changed America's attitude toward firefighting, and the thousands of fire lookout towers that were built across the nation in its wake. Find that article only at ninipi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上关注我 Roman Mars，或者关注节目 99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但本周在 99PI 网站上，有一篇关于 1910 年大火的文章，那场大火改变了美国对消防的态度，以及随后在全国范围内建造的数千座火警瞭望塔。请在 ninipi.org 网站上查看该文章。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。